I think I'm happiest when I'm touching
dough and when I'm baking bread finding
my passion and form of making sourdough
bread I kind of feel like falling in
love
I'm Marissa Bui I live in Los Angeles
California
my passion is sourdough bread baking and
I'm following my food dreams I knew I
loved food I just didn't know that I
wanted it to be my career or my path in
life so I think for a long time I was
just kind of floating around the food
space you know doing a little bit of
pastry doing a little bit of recipe
development and it just felt more like a
day job I you know felt okay about it
basically but I wasn't passionate about
it I wasn't going to work and be like I
want to make these products I'm making
and then when I made my first loves of
bread and I was like aha
this is what I want to be doing I think
why sourdough totally hooked me is
because of its simplicity a croissant is
beautiful because it has layers of
butter and sugar and you have to spend
hours putting it you know rolling it
super thin and making it a certain shape
but a loaf of bread is just flour water
salt and your hands coming together to
make like a Risen beautiful loaf of
bread even though it wasn't my job I was
like this is what I want to be doing all
the time it was something I was thinking
about something I wanted to explore on
my own time to make it better to make a
loaf that someone would really enjoy or
a specific loaf that someone was looking
for and craving because it's what
they're grabbing is to make them when
they were a kid and and that's it
consumed my day in the best sort of way
you know I get in my head a lot and I
have a lot of fears about like should I
quit my day job and go work at a bakery
to gain the experience that I need you
know there's a point where I'm making
bread every single day at my house and
I'm like what's next I've turned my
house into a bakery - my wife's chagrin
and I I need an outlet where I can like
learn more and even if it's a little
scary or intimidating just dive right in
recently I took a bet on myself I quit
my day job I moved 30 miles north and I
got a full-time job at a bakery it was a
it was scary because it wanted something
new you know I'm I'm not a bread
professional I'm going into a space
where people have been working in bread
for years and and they really know what
they're doing so it's it's a little it's
a little intimidating but I knew if I
didn't if I didn't go take this bakery
job that I would be staying in a day job
that was relatively easy comfortable fun
but I would always have in the back of
my head that I didn't go chase my dreams
and I feel like one day I look back when
I was 40 or 50 or 70 or 80 and I'll say
why didn't I go take that chance when I
had it when when it was like right there
in front of me yeah I don't want that
moment to come I want I want to say that
I want to be able to say in five years
when I have this bakery space that I'm
that I'm hoping to have one day that I
did go follow my dreams and I think this
is the first step that I'm taking
happiness looks like being able to share
the bread that I make with other people
watching those people share what they
know with others my ultimate sourdough
dream is to share my love of bread with
other people through a small intimate
baking space where I can make bread and
give it to people and I can also teach
people how to make their own bread
I think that's what some what's the most
thrilling about sourdough to me is that
every time I bake bread and make the
dough it's different and I'm still
enthralled by it it kind of feels like
it kind of feels like following in love
because you're like obsessed with it
you're thinking about it all the time
and and you want to learn more about it
and it doesn't stop it hasn't stopped
things it's only been a couple of years
but I imagine it's not gonna stop
chasing my dreams like feels like I got
on a train that is going really fast and
it's a little scary but I'm like hanging
on for dear life and I'm really excited
for where it's gonna take me I had been
held back by thinking oh like you know I
can't do that I'm I'm young I don't you
know I don't have a lot of money or I I
don't have the resources to do that but
you can you can make the business that
you want to make if you have the skills
to do it and the creativity and also the
passion because it's a lot of hard work
so seeing other people chase their
dreams and makes make their passions a
reality has allowed me to feel like I
can do that too my name is Marissa Bui
my passion is sourdough bread baking and
I'm following my food dreams oh yes
[Music]
you
[Music]